كلما تقدمت تقنيه الذكاء الاصطناعي استفاد
الانسان لكن القلق يظل حاضرا ايضا الامر
يشكل خطرا وجوديا على حياتنا
بحسبث المدير التنفيذي السابق لشركه جوجل
وهذا القلق يتنامم منذ ظهور تشات ودلئي
والتساؤل المخيف هو هل يستولي الذكاء
الاصطناعي على وظائفنا نعم بعض الوظائف
ستكون في خطر فمن سيكون ضحيه الذكاء
الاصطناعي الوظائف التقنيه هي الاكثر عرضه
للخطر مثل البرمجه وتحليل البيانات ستنتج
الاكواد باسرع مما يمكن انتاجه من طرف
البشر وبتكلفه اقل حتى ان شركه اوبن اي اي
مصممه تشاد جي بي تي بدات بتدريب تقنيه
الذكاء الاصطناعي على برمجه الحواسيب
وظائف الاعلام هي الاخرى معرضه لخطر
الانقراض الاعلانات والصحافه مثلا ما
السبب قدرته الذكاء الاصطناعي على قراءه
البيانات النصيه وكتابتها وفهمها والقائها
وهنا المهدد انا على الجانب الاخر ستبقى
بعض الوظائف خاصه بالانسان فقط المحامون
والقضاه مثلا فالذكاء الاصطناعي لا يمكنه
قراءه المشاعر رغم ان تشاد جي بي تي اربعه
تحديدا نبات يتقدم في هذه المنطقه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات